in this episode of cloud performance
atlas I helped some tax experts gain
performance independence if their
friends performance jumped off a cliff
would they do too stay tuned to find out
tax lemming is a start-up focused on
making sense of purchases taxes and
basic bookkeeping for your small
business needs but they had a problem
that was keeping them from going for
their next round of VC funding they've
got too many instances spinning up and
it was breaking the bank see in a rush
to put together a working prototype the
tax lemmings client hit a Google load
balancer which fetched content from a GC
instance running Apache now to improve
performance their lead engineer wanted
to move to a very traditional solution
for web-based applications adding a
layer of nginx instances to acts as a
reverse caching proxy to the Apache
servers and then change the client to
fetch static content directly from a CDN
instead of the back-end instances now
this is a very tried and true solution
but before they started tearing things
up I wanted to present them with an
alternative way to get the same caching
performance but with less instances and
lower costs using GCPs
load balancers see one secret that GCP
load balancers have is that with the
click of a button button the load
balancer will cache requests and move
them to a google cloud CDN to reduce
latency on your behalf as long as the
request is cached it will be served
directly at Google's Network edge rather
than going to the backend
performance-wise this is a huge boost we
can easily see the difference when
comparing direct access to the resource
through the instance versus allowing the
load balancer to cache the request this
graph shows that once the asset gets
cached the response time drops
significantly and all you had to do was
check a box what's even better about
this is that the cached content is
served right from Google CDN without any
need for caching instances to exist to
use a new buzzword you could call this
service I'm cool now another nifty
feature that the load balancers allow
you to do is create hosts routing paths
for your domain which will serve content
directly from a Google cloud storage
bucket this way you don't have to modify
the client to fetch new types of content
from a different CDN location
instead you can just treat the assets as
though they were sub-directories and the
load balancers will do the right thing
and of course to improve performance
further you can even cache those assets
to the CDN as well so with a few button
clicks tax lemmings was able to cut down
their instance count and reduce their
maintenance headaches long term if you'd
like more details on this problem check
out the full article linked in the
description below and make sure to
subscribe to our google cloud YouTube
channel to get alerts when new
performance videos comes out and don't
forget when it comes to performance
every millisecond counts